I'm Ian Davis and I uh I work as a
product engineer at Prismatic um and I'm
here to talk about the challenges and
benefits of a functional reactive front
end um really excited to give this talk
uh and have been for a long time and
then I found out I was going right after
rich on the main stage and my brain
still hurts a little um but but I think
it'll be a good talk um so I want to
start off with this quote by Tony
um which some you have probably heard of
before it says that there are two ways
of constructing a software design one is
to make it so simple that there are no
deficiencies and the other way is to
make it so complicated that there are no
obvious deficiencies the first method is
far more difficult and the reason I like
this quote is because it touches on
something that rich hickey talked about
on this very stage a couple of years ago
that there's a significant difference
between simple and easy easy means
something is near at hand or easily
accessible while simple implies sort of
a lack of complexity that it only does
one thing um and it's important to note
that ease does not necessarily imply
Simplicity in fact without a lot of work
ease can often lead to something that's
very
complex um so what is this talk actually
going to be about um well the goal is to
assemble a flexible toolbox that sort of
simplifies the traditional complexities
of web development um at Prismatic we
have a pretty heavy emphasis on design
and we're still figuring out our core
product which means that we can't really
rely on an architecture that assumes
anything about our application state or
structure um so we need something that's
flexible that lets us build quickly and
iterate fast um we're also very
functional um we've used closure to
great success on the back end and so we
wanted to see what technologies out
there can we use to apply a lot of the
same principles to front-end web
development um so more specifically I'm
going to talk about what the sort of
traditional complexities in JavaScript
are and where they come from um and then
I'm going to talk about why closure
script is a good solution for for
solving a lot of these complexity and
gives us a lot of good basic tools um to
help out web development and then I'm
going to talk about uh react a
JavaScript framework by by Facebook and
how it's functional approach to Dom
manipulation is is really better than
anything else out there if you want to
do sort of functional declarative UI
development um then I'm going to talk
about M which is a library that combines
closure script and react together and it
gives us some really nice benefits of
the marriage of these two technologies
and uh finally I'm going to wrap up by
talking about sort of the the Practical
challenges and benefits that we get from
this architecture um as far as I know
we're the largest production omap um and
we're certainly one of the largest
closure script apps as well um and so
there's a lot of things that we've sort
of of benefits that we've gotten and
hopefully this will help you decide if
if this this might work for you um so
let's start with with what problems
JavaScript has um the first book that
most web developers are typically handed
is Javascript the good parts um and
that's because the good parts of
JavaScript are are actually a quite
small subset of the language as a whole
um how many of you have ever
participated in a hackathon
before um and now keep Your Hand raised
or raise your hand again if you are
really proud of the quality of your code
at the end of that
hackathon
um JavaScript was made in 10 days in May
and Brandon Nike shipped it as a
prototype far too soon and he wasn't
really able to go back and change it and
I think sort of this is where a lot of
Javas scripts inconsistencies and quirks
come from you get things like the double
equals a quality operator that that
automatically typ casts everything to a
string because that makes a lot of sense
when you're when you're trying to
determine if things are equal
um and when you combine that with their
original design goals that they they
wanted a language for non Java
programmers non-programmers even which
could be written directly in HTML
something that designers beginners and
amateurs could learn by the yard with
this really boils down to is that
JavaScript was designed to be easy and
accessible and it actually worked out
pretty great for the web you know the
the dev console's right there you can
get immediately results and I think this
easiness is what's made it one of the
most ubiquitous platforms out there um a
lot of designers I know can can code in
JavaScript and and do HTML and CSS but
the number of Javas or sorry the number
of designers who can write an IOS app or
an Android app I can basically count on
one hand um but if you think back to our
our Tony quote simple is hard and
making something that's both easy and
simple is even harder and Netscape just
didn't invest the time required to make
things simple and easy so we're left
with a language and a platform that's
simple and quite complic or sorry that's
that's easy and quite complicated um and
there's a lot of unpredictability that
comes from these pitfalls um the most
common example people use is is this
sort of implicit glob
which in this function here I'm trying
to define a local variable but if I
accidentally forget the VAR declaration
which is very easy to do suddenly I'm
mutating this this variable in the scope
above mine
um and JavaScript just assumes that that
this is what you want to do and if you
don't have a global variable there
that's okay it it'll go ahead and create
one for you um and even when you know
about this Pitfall it's very easy to
forget and JavaScript doesn't really
throw any errors to to tell you that you
might have made a mistake and it gets
even more insane when you consider
hoisting because even though this is
defined without the VAR statement at the
Top If someone else much later in this
function defines it with a VAR statement
that'll automatically get hoisted to the
top meaning that it's impossible to tell
at first glance whether I'm dealing with
a local or a global variable
um but the problem here isn't
the global hoisting it's it's the fact
that you have this Global mutable State
and this is a problem even on local
levels um when I pass in Fu I don't
really know what that function is doing
to it it could come back out anything
else um and if you do have a bug in your
code tracking it down is a nightmare
because you know it could have been
mutated by any one of these functions
there's there's no way to easily track
where these changes are being made
um and I think that with JavaScript you
really need something that's that's
going to warn you of these pitfalls it's
going to make sure that you don't make
the easy mistakes um and for a lot of
people the solution is is JS lint which
is a good way to prevent a lot of the
more sort of silly things that
JavaScript does but things like mutable
State JS lint doesn't really corre for
because you know that's that's an
opinion that the language has that
making things easier with mutable state
is a good idea um and we sort of
disagree which is why we chose closure
script as our language of choice um
unlike some of the the sort of
JavaScript compiled languages out there
it's not just cosmetic differences um
closure script actually adds real value
to our development process um it creates
a very simple set of sort of basic tools
and with the power of macros that allows
it to be really really easily extendable
so that we can write our own tools to
sort of build upon the language
itself um so if we look at at lexical
scoping
um this is sort of how you do it in
JavaScript and it looks structurally
very similar to the let binding and
closure script and that's because
closure script basically takes the the
best practices that you should otherwise
be doing in JavaScript and it of
enforces and codifies them in the code
um and there's no way to sort of
accidentally up this Le binding
because you know mutable refs are so
much different than normal immutable
values that you really really know when
you're changing something
um and you
you sort of the same reason that we like
a good type system or a good test Suite
closure script provides these guard
rails that prevents us from sort of
using the bad parts of JavaScript and
falling into these
pitfalls
um and this I think is another example
of something in JavaScript that's that's
sort of incidentally complex there's
four different there's four sort of
slightly different ways that this gets
bound and it gets magically bound behind
the scenes and once you've been
programming for a long time you you
learn to memorize these four different
ways but it's really not necessary for
there to be four different ways is in
closure script we only have one method
of of sort of binding this and we're not
even binding it it's explicitly passed
in as the first argument to to protocol
functions
um and so I I think JavaScript is
getting a lot better and so I want to
talk a little bit about about sort of
ecmascript 6 because they' they've got a
lot of nice things that are coming down
the line that are trying to improve the
language um there's some bad things too
and they still have to leave a lot of
these pitfalls in there for for
backwards compatibility but this is one
of those and this is um um the yield
operator which allows you to create in
this case an infinite sequence of
Fibonacci numbers and it gives you back
a generator that you sort of call next
on to get each next value um
and in closure script we sort of already
have the ability to build up a lazy
sequence like this very easily
um I think it's a little bit cleaner to
have you know a long lazy sequence that
you can use sequence processing
functions on it's it's still immutable
you don't have this this sort of
stateful object that you have to keep
calling the next method on um but I
think more importantly I can ship this
code right now and I think this is true
of a lot of the good things that are
sort of you know a couple months or a
couple years down the line with
ecmascript 6 is that closure script sort
of already has this functionality right
now and something like transducers which
was just announced we could put into our
code and ship right now without having
to wait for for browser manufacturers to
actually integrate it into their runtime
because it compiles down to a very basic
set of JavaScript that's already
supported on all
platforms um and it also lets us to to
build our own tools really
easily and in this case I want to I want
to talk about you know this this nested
Json map we've got
the data that we actually want to ask
access is three levels deep um and we've
got this function that you know we want
to pull out the data transform it in
some way but we also want to assert in a
safe way that all of the values we have
actually exist and that they conform to
the types that we expect them to and
this is the only real business logic of
this code the rest of it is just sort of
annotation and and data extraction and
so um for us at Prismatic we've taken
our two popular open source libraries
plumbing and schema and we've made them
work in closure script as well as
closure so this gives us some nice the
nice ability to do this sort of
map
extraction in the actual destructuring
of arguments and if you look down uh at
the last three arguments we have these
type annotations of string number and
Boolean
and schema will actually throw errors if
a key isn't present or if it doesn't
conform to our expected
type
um and and so that that gives us a lot
more safety and this is all because
closure script provides the ability to
sort of reshape the language to our
specific use cases um you know there's a
lot of people in the closure Community
who don't necessarily like these type
annotations but for us they're a huge
benefit and so we get to pick and choose
which parts are most useful to us and
which parts we want to extend further
functionality with and we can do it
without really giving up any of the
existing Java JavaScript ecosystem um in
this case calculating the length of a
tweet I don't know if any of you have
tried to do this it's actually kind of
complicated because you have to
determine what's actually a URL and
there there are a lot of edge cases with
URL detection but Twitter provides a
really really nice Li library for doing
a lot of this stuff in JavaScript and so
for us we can use and import that
JavaScript library very easily so that
sort of 99% of the clode we write is
still inclosure script and still gives
us all the benefits of that but when we
do need to use an existing JavaScript
library the interop is very very
simple so now I I want to move on and
talk a little bit about da manipulation
specifically how react has a much more
functional approach
than everything else is out there um the
Dom and HTML was initially designed as a
way to mark up static content that's
coming down from the server and then
slowly over time people wanted a a
little bit of interaction here and there
and now we're in a stage where you know
you want these large interactive web
apps but you have this imperative API
for Dom interaction that's that's not
really good for these large web apps I
think if if any of us were to design a
system purely code you know no one would
think that the best way to to manage
your data is to have a large globally
accessible mutable object that
everything just pounds on at once um but
that's what we have to do with the
Dom so I want to talk a little bit about
an example from Prismatic and and how
our product works is that we have a
variety of different feeds that are
about a specific Topic in this case
Urban exploration and the feed is a
collection of stories
that are tagged with specific topics so
since this is the urban exploration feed
everything is about Urban exploration
but the top article is also about Japan
and the second article is also about
water um and a user can follow a topic
to indicate that they want more content
about that
particular um topic and so when the user
actually follows a topic the underlying
data change is actually very very simple
we're just toggling a Boolean somewhere
in our dat model that says you know
you're now following Urban exploration
but that change has to be updated
multiple places in the Dom and and when
you're doing this manually um it's it's
really hard to remember all of the
differences and detect all of the
differences here and you're really just
inviting Errors By not um by not
creating a system that that manages this
for you um it's it's sort of human
nature to be forgetful and anytime it's
easy to forget something there's going
to be a bug and the more things you have
to remember the more forgetful you're
going to be um and nobody really does
this manual anymore everyone's using
sort of a lot of MVC Frameworks but i'
argue that a lot of these MVC Frameworks
aren't actually that much simpler um you
have to use mutable state to do them so
all it really does is it takes your Dom
mutation and it shifts all of that
mutable code into your your JavaScript
um
and the the there's this tight binding
between sort of the tight coupling
between templates and your data that
that really doesn't suggest that they
should be in separate places um and when
you do actually separate them out you
have enough you need enough control flow
in your templating language that you end
up inviting a inventing a whole second
domain specific language just to do
templating when you already have a fully
featured Lang language that you're doing
the rest of your development in um and
so we chose react as opposed to to you
know angular Ember one of these because
it completely encapsulates and ex um
abstracts away the Dom so we never
actually interact with the Dom ourselves
we just interact with react components
and they propagate all of the necessary
changes for
us and how a particular react component
works is it has um
um it's a functional mapping it has a
render function which is a functional
mapping from our data to Virtual Dom of
what it would look like if that were the
data and so we get all of the Power and
expressivity of closure script or
JavaScript when we're writing these
render functions and you get this sort
of fully declarative completely refer
referentially transparent way of
describing what your Dom should look
like and it encapsulates sort of all of
the dynamic interactions and all of the
dynamic state in a s single function so
it's really really easy to reason about
exactly what the Dom is going to look
like given what your data looks like um
and this actually makes it a lot easier
to test because you do have this
functional mapping from data to Dom um
and I mentioned this before but it's
it's worth repeating again we're
outputting virtual Dom here not not
actual real Dom and you can still
compose these functions together the
these components together in a way that
basically builds up a hierarchy um
similar to the way you would do a Dom
and and how this works now is when a
user follows an interest um they follow
the the travel interest in this case and
that propagates back to the data and
then react recomputes the entire virtual
Dom which sounds really inefficient but
it's far more inefficient to touch the
real Dom and so doing all of this in
code is actually quite fast um and then
react automatically does a diff on the
current virtual Dom
and um the real Dom and only actually
writes the minimal change set so this
essentially takes away all of the
complexity that we would have had to do
before of thinking about exactly where
and how we need to update the Dom all we
do is we write this component hierarchy
once and then our actual interactions
are just changing our application State
and everything else immediately
propagates from there um as sort of a an
added benefit event handlers become
almost trivial to write um the reason
event handlers are typically complicated
in web development isn't because it's
hard to write a function that that sort
of toggles a bulin it's because you get
a lot of complexity from sort of the
overhead of event handlers um you have
to make sure that you're not listening
more than once that you you you don't
accidentally set it up twice that the
node you're trying to listen to actually
exists right now um or that there
there's no reference Loops between the
Dom and your JavaScript and and really
when you're writing them in line on
components that get blown away and
updated as needed you don't have to
worry about any of this overhead anymore
um and it it it really lets you focus on
the core problem which is changing your
application State not worrying about how
to change and mutate the
Dom
um so M combines react enclosure script
in a in a really nice way that that sort
of adds a lot of nice benefits for us
um the first is that that we centralize
our entire App State um so that all of
our event handlers and all of our um
client server Communications all go to
one giant mutable ref um and this allows
us to sort of
duplicate all of our client side state
and put everything in a single canonical
place makes it much easier to reason
about the sort of direct mapping to our
full application state to our full Dom
rendering which gives us some nice the
realization benefits um but you know at
first glance that that sounds really bad
because having a single giant mutable
reference means that you know we can't
easily
decompose into subcomponents because
because how atoms work in closure script
is you sort of swap the entire value all
at once um and and this is Trivial to do
with immutable data because you can just
pass down a smaller piece of your data
and keep a pointer to it and let the
child mutate it but it becomes much
harder when you want to do this in an
immutable way and so the M provides a
tool called cursors which allows us to
take this large application State and
boil it down to just the actual part
that we care about um it provides a a
window basically into the the managed
ref as a whole that we can treat just
like an atom and when we update this
atom it immediately propagates that
change back to the application State as
a whole and so this allows us to sort of
decomplex all of our components from the
actual application structure um while
maintaining the benefits of immutable
data and so if we look at um this code
here we we have in Prismatic the notion
of a paginated list which which is a
items a next URL to fetch more items and
a remaining count and this is the way
that we take sort of long sequences like
our our SC scrolling feeds and break
them up into reasonable chunks
and because react handles all of the the
rendering whenever our data changes if
we want to generate a full feed this is
all of the code we need it takes in one
of these paginated lists it doesn't care
what kind of list it is or what the
objects are in that list it just fetches
more from the server using the the sort
of same core abstraction and paginates
everything
in um and sort of the ability to to fill
out an entire feed of information
without ever actually thinking about the
Dom means that our our concerns really
are separated in a way that they
wouldn't be in another
architecture um so now I want to talk
about sort of what this you know having
this large mutable object actually gives
us some some pretty neat performance
benefits um when using oh because react
has this method uh called should
component update which gets called every
time it's about to recompute a a
particular virtual Dom from your
component and um it defaults to True
which is why the entire tree got
rendered last time um and it defaults to
true because it's it's actually really
complicated to tell if your reference to
a piece of mutable data is is different
or not you essentially would have to
walk the entire data structure on both
sides to determine equality um but in
this particular case we can do a simple
fast reference of quality check on our
immutable data and that allows us to
sort of
prune parts of the tree that we don't
actually need to recompute so the only
parts that that really get recomputed
here are the parts that have actually
changed
um and afterwards react still does the
same sort of minimal change set to the
Dom so really all we're doing is we're
we're eliminating all of this
intermediate work that we would
otherwise do that that's really not
necessary
um and
so I want to talk about the the last
section which is sort of is it ready for
production um which is the most common
question I get when I'm trying to talk
about this with people um and I think
the answer is is mostly yes um it works
really really great for us in production
um but it sort of really depends on your
team and I think for most people in this
crowd um the the answer is probably yes
too
um our architecture is a lot simpler
than it used to be um before we switched
over the the sort of complexity had
almost paralyzed our development because
everything was so intertwined that
whenever we tried to make a change we
would have to sort of
refactor parts of our code base just to
make even even small changes um and I I
don't know if this is true for other
people but I I get a lot of joy out of
using such a well-designed abstraction
and for me the sort of I'm I'm basically
spending my entire day writing pure
function
um either you know data processing
functions in in closure script or or
these nice you know render functions
that that take in data and directly
output to Dom there's there's less
finickiness than I I used to have to
deal with um and there's also a lot less
context than I think there was before um
in our case our back end and our front
end now use the same language um so any
engineer is comfortable with with sort
of anything in our codee base and right
now the only way to achieve that on the
web is to use node on the back end and
as a sort of you know machine learning
and natural language processing company
that's not really an option for us um
and I it's also everything is is sort of
fully functional and referentially
transparent so even an engineer who
doesn't understand our system can come
in and very very easily see how a piece
of data is being being transformed into
the Dom because it's sort of all laid
out for him there in a single function
um so sort of anyone can jump in and
immediately feel feel comfortable making
changes um which actually is is really
useful for us because we're a fairly
small product team but we have a lot of
backend Engineers who want product
changes in the app um it's also
extremely expressive um one of my
co-workers wrote 2048 uh the the sort of
popular game in about 200 lines and um
David Nolan in his post introducing this
wrote that to- do MVC app in about
260 um and this expressiveness scales to
larger code bases as well um when we
implemented this system for the first
time we went from sort of 26,000 lines
of code to a little over 5,000 um which
is which is a pretty big reduction for
us um and it's because it's so much
easier to reason about and all the
context you need is is sort of in one
place you get a lot fewer bugs than than
I think we used to have
um now these are these are sort of only
the the small ones that come from these
inconsistencies every once in a while
you you still get you know you you still
have typos and and they're usually a lot
harder to track down when you do get
them but um overall I think the the sort
of volume of bugs
decreases um and when you actually
compare it to a similar backbone
architecture um it it ends up being two
to four times faster uh for the for Tod
do MVC
benchmarks and um this wasn't even
really a priority for us um we're not at
the sort of performance optimization
stage um but it is a really really nice
benefit and I think all of these things
be besides just you know uh application
speed um all of these things together
combin to make you know a much faster
development speed and there's there's no
real tangible proof I can give to that
besides our anecdotal experiences but
but you know we we are building things
faster and we're we're making you know
drastic redesigns or or experimenting
with new products in a way that that we
couldn't have done under our old
architecture
um and there are definitely some caveats
um that makes it not necessarily right
for everyone uh I think it requires a a
fundamentally different way of of
thinking about UI development um in the
same way that that when you first go
from sort of an imperative
objectoriented language to something
that's more
functional um you have to sort of switch
your thinking um when you move from
traditional Dom manipulation to react
you you have to go through a similar
mental shift um and it's it's not a big
mental leap but but you definitely do
have to reason and structure your
application much differently than you
would under another
system um
and it you sort of have to figure things
out on your own you you have to figure
out how to structure things differently
and
you know closure script M and react are
are very new compared to angular or
JavaScript and so when you run into a
problem you know it's not going to be
easy to just go to Google or stock
overflow and find the answer to it um
there there's not nearly as much of an
ecosystem or as many developers around
these Technologies yet um but if you're
sort of willing to to be adventurous um
they do have a a lot of performance
benefits um and for us because we have
our entire team on the language we don't
have any sort of uh uh downsides of of
people speaking different languages um
which can frequently be a problem in
larger
organizations
um and I think the the sort
of uh I want to I want to give it so I'm
I'm sort of wrapping up here I want to
give a huge thanks to to you know the
cognitech guys and and the react team
cuz they really you know made these
language and made these Frameworks or
libraries I should say and and sort of
trailblazed in a way that allowed us to
to develop such a clean
architecture
um I think that that it's really easy to
try these things out um closure script
maybe a little bit harder um but you
know immutable data there are a lot of
good JavaScript libraries out there for
it um and react itself
we specifically first tried it on a
settings page um without you know
rearching our whole app and and Facebook
only uses it in for small parts of the
interaction on on the Facebook app and
so you know if if you're thinking about
this I I really do encourage you to to
try it in a small piece first see how
you like it and then if you're convinced
uh sort of move to a larger a larger
implementation um and then the last
thing I want to do is is sort of give us
thanks to to everyone at the Prismatic
where I worked
um first for sort of letting us try
crazy new architectures like this um and
and I think we we implemented M about a
month after it was first open sourced um
so we were we were definitely in the
early development phase and you
know they also helped me refine a lot of
this talk and and listen to me you know
talk at them over and over and over
again um so yeah I want to just give a a
huge
thanks um any
questions
um yes and no uh we basically we tried
it
on an experimental feature Branch um so
we tried it for an independent project
that wasn't our main app um and then
slowly that that sort of independent
project evolved into a redesign of our
main app and then we switched everything
over um so there was definitely a period
where we were sort of supporting both
JavaScript and uh where we were
supporting two different apps um inter
no not with interrupt there was it was
just you know two branches we had we had
the old version running and we would go
and fix bugs on it but but all of our
new feature development was happening in
closure script um but that only lasted
for you know a couple months um
yeah um well so it's first off it's not
actually Global it's a single App State
but it's it's passed into to the root
component and then decomposed from there
um I think the reason that we wanted to
decompose it is
because um like in
in this case you know writing an
interest label that has the entire
application State linked to it is is
really complexing a lot of things
together that means every single
component in this tree has to know about
the full the full state of the app um
and I think for us because we were
already using closure script the idea of
using one giant immutable ref just sort
of came naturally from
that no this is this is how M works out
of the box yeah so this this wasn't our
Innovation this uh this came from David
Nolan anything else
yep
um so the question is you have inputs
coming from user interaction and you
have inputs coming from the server and
did that cause any problem s for us um
and I think the the really nice thing
about
using a mutable or a managed ref in
closure here is that you know you get
JavaScript isn't multi-threaded but you
get a lot of the same benefits as if you
were doing multi-threading with these
Atomic updates so all you just have to
make sure that you're because you're
going from sort of Old State to New
State um it's it's almost imp possible
for the data to get out of sync um and
so sort of the worst thing that can
happen is um you know a user like double
clicks a button and we've updated
something locally and then a server
request comes back and sort of
overwrites their change but the minute
that change gets overrided it's
overridden it's going to be reflected in
the UI by react and so the user knows
what the underlying state is in a really
transparent way which allows them to
sort of undo that
um I think it it avoids because of this
sort of managed um full State transfer
it avoids getting different places out
of sync with each other which is usually
the the problem
there anyone
else
feler
cool